well I will say that I haven't again I
haven't played it yet but so I'll give
my initial reactions upon seeing it and
I'm kind of in the in the same boat as
addict when I saw it I rolled my eyes
but I rolled my eyes
because I was like oh man here's the
game the the PlayStation boy is gonna
come for us and it's the cartoony Xbox
games never doing something like you
know that's grounded and looks on the
level so I'm like here we go but just
immediately looking at it I was like oh
no here's here's the janitors passion
project you know you know actually let
me say something real quick so someone
just put in the chat
these people
should have made battle tones
like some kind of art style and I feel
like they could have took the gameplay
in a good direction it's just
I actually do feel like Tango was one of
the lower echelons there was nothing
wrong with